it would be an understatement to say
that Britain and the USA's relationship
got off to a rocky start in 1812 Britain
and America were at war but just over a
century later they were fighting
shoulder-to-shoulder in World War one
which obviously raises the question when
did Britain and America become allies
they had to be a point where both went
from actively disliking each other to
working alongside each other now before
continuing it's important to note that
even in the immediate aftermath of
independence America and Britain still
had strong economic ties this isn't to
say that things were always great
between the two and there were some
pretty major conflicts of interest in
the years after the war of 1812 finished
the first and perhaps the most obvious
was the Monroe Doctrine established in
1823 this was where the United States by
threat of military intervention declared
an end to any new European colonial
adventures in the Americas and for
Britain this was potentially a problem
because it had economic interest in
South America in reality though it
wasn't too much of a problem at all
because in 1833 it landed a force and
the Falkland Islands and America did
nothing in 1842 the u.s. did warn
Britain against interference in Hawaii
which Britain did heed because America's
international power was certainly
growing and it was this fact that
America was a rapidly growing great
power whose interest could no longer be
ignored which would dominate
anglo-american relations to the
following century so the next major
event which could have changed the
anglo-american dynamic was the American
civil war which broke out in 1861
Britain had already abolished slavery at
this point in so you would think that it
would have preferred the Union over the
Confederacy but you'd be wrong now
Britain had no great affection for the
Confederacy in its lay voting practices
its preferential treatment was purely
economic mostly due to cotton imports
Britain did consider formally
recognizing the Confederacy in
anglo-american relations were severely
harmed by what's called the Trent affair
this was where the US government seized
a ship with Confederate diplomats headed
for Britain which to Britain looked like
the USA telling it who it could and
could not speak to in the end cooler
heads prevailed and Britain didn't get
involved although it did construct a
very powerful warship the CSS Alabama
for the Confederacy and after the Civil
War was over Britain paid compensation
to the United States thus only fifty
years away from World War one Britain
and America still didn't really care
much for each other so what changed this
well relations actually started to
improve during Britain's border dispute
with Venezuela in 1895 this developed
into somewhat of a crisis and the u.s.
intervened and arbitrated siding mostly
with Britain for Britain America had
conducted itself in a well-mannered
fashion and given
Britta most of what it had wanted and
for America by accepting American
Arbitration Britain had yielded its
right to influence South America the
other reason for anglo-american reproach
meant was simple converging interests
America had emerged from its Civil War a
more centralized industrial power and
after its defeat of Spain in 1898 it
possessed a global Empire to and for
Britain things were rapidly changing as
well its empire and global position was
being threatened by Russia and the newly
formed Germany Britain had long
practiced a policy of isolationism with
respect to the European powers but since
they too were industrializing this had
the potential to threaten Britain's
position thus her most natural ally
seemed to be the United States since it
was half a world away and had its own
sphere of influence plus they spoke the
same language and shared many values it
was at the turn of the 20th century
under President Theodore Roosevelt the
dimeric around Britain really started to
become friends particularly with respect
to one foreign policy stance they didn't
like Germany this agreement allowed for
Britain to move its fleet away from its
Caribbean colonies back to Britain to
defend itself from Germany while
security in the Caribbean would fall to
the US after the first world war broke
out Germany's actions such as u-boat
attacks on American shipping in the
Zimmerman telegram combined with the
fact that if Britain and France lost the
war they wouldn't be able to pay their
American loans back assured US
intervention on their side and from that
point onwards both the US and UK were
largely in the same camps barring a
couple of mishaps here and there I hope
you enjoyed this episode and thank you
for watching with extra thanks to these
patrons you can see on screen for their
continued support and an extra special
thanks to James Bissonnette David
archaeologists as ARCA Flash Danny
Maloney party-boy Koch coolin Castleman
Rob Waterhouse Chris wicker Gustav Swan
David Silverman Winston Kate woods
Christian checky Maggie packs Kowski
Lexi Schwinn Anthony Beckett Robert
Wetzel Skye Chappell Ike spinning three
plates are on the white and Michael
Reynolds